You're at home watching a movie.
Maybe it's a great film, or maybe it's just
a guilty pleasure, but you know for sure there's
that one scene you just don't want to watch.
It's too cringe-worthy, too scary, too disturbing,
too stupid — or even too boring — so you
grab the remote so you can fast forward to
the next watchable scene.
Don't worry, everyone's done it.
Here are some of the movie moments that many
of us prefer to skip right over.
Spoilers ahead, of course.
Jaws
This Steven Spielberg classic still gives
everyone shark nightmares, and it all stems
from its opening scene.
The poor doomed Chrissie goes for a moonlight
skinny dip after a party on the beach.
We see something approach her dangling legs
from under the water — and you can probably
guess where it goes from there.
With terror in her eyes, she's whipped around
for what seems like forever, screaming things
like...
"Oh it hurts!"
...until she's finally pulled under for good.
Better to just move along because we all know
the real fun of Jaws is watching Brody, Hooper,
and Quint on the boat, hashing it out with
the shark.
Scarface
The rags-to-riches story of a Cuban immigrant
who becomes a drug lord only to see his empire
crumble at his bloodied, cocaine-caked feet.
It's a given that Scarface is a very violent
experience — but one scene featuring a chainsaw
takes it to another level.
Early in the game, some seriously angry Colombians
show Tony Montana why you don't mess with
them by taking a chainsaw to one of his friends
while he has to watch.
Sure, there are plenty of horror movies that
use this particular tool to gruesome effect
— and you may choose to skip over those
scenes as well — but when it comes to the
Scarface chainsaw scene, you'll definitely
want to sit this one out.
Misery
You don't really see it coming, but when whackadoo
Annie decides she needs to teach her "favorite"
author Paul a lesson after he breaks her rules,
it's pretty horrifying.
With Paul tied to a bed with a wooden block
between his feet, Annie starts talking about
how he needs a good "hobbling" to make him
realize he can never leave her — and then
she takes a sledgehammer and crushes his ankles
on both sides.
It's just too painful to watch.
"Almost done."
By the way, in Stephen King's novel, Annie
does far worse things to poor Paul, but you
can skip past those pages as well.
Marathon Man
Anyone who's seen Marathon Man probably gets
a toothache just thinking about it.
This superb crime thriller film sees graduate
student Babe caught up in a spy game that
involves a Nazi war criminal — a skilled
dentist whose specialty in the concentration
camps was, well, you get the picture.
He captures Babe and tortures him, all while
asking...
"Is it safe?"
No, it's not safe, and anyone with a dentist
phobia — which is pretty much everyone — will
probably push that fast-forward button.
127 Hours
If you know the true story of Aron Ralston,
a mountain climber who became trapped under
a boulder while hiking alone, you know the
desperate measures he had to take in order
to survive.
Played by James Franco in the film, Aron has
to saw off part of his arm in order to free
himself and stay alive.
When it comes to that moment in 127 Hours,
you think you're prepared, but you're really
not.
Director Danny Boyle masterfully captures
the essence of the scene, Franco brilliantly
plays it, and they should be applauded for
it.
But no one needs to watch it again.
2001: A Space Odyssey
Look, we all know this 1968 Stanley Kubrick
film was way ahead of its time when it was
released, and is widely regarded as a cinematic
classic from a master director.
It is a spectacularly visual film worthy of
its praise.
But man, that first ten minutes, with the
apes and the black monolith, will put you
right to sleep.
"I don't know what you're talking about."
Just skip all that and get to the meat of
the film, in which a ship computer goes creepily
rogue after it realizes the humans might turn
it off.
In the battle of evil computers versus dumb
monkeys, computers always win.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!